cinq ans et demi plus tard la chambre
106 du bâtiment rousseau est toujours
sanctuariser scène de crime ou pas elle
est un lieu clé lorsque les amis de
narumi tambourine à sa porte le 5
décembre quelques heures après les cris
déchirants entendu dans la résidence
nicolas zepeda est toujours à
l'intérieur cela il ne le nie pas mais
selon lui narumi est toujours vivante
elle lui fait signe de garder le silence
écrit à ses amis qu'elle est partie
l'accusé n'en démord pas elle veut
rester seul avec lui les retrouvailles
sont torrides les parties civiles
s'interroge néanmoins vous passé 30
heures passionnés enfermer tous les deux
vous repartez et vous l'a rappelé pas
jamais même lorsqu'elle disparaît
peut-être parce qu'on appelle pas un
mort nicolas cepeda essuie quelques
larmes un moment de faiblesse qui ne
dure pas avec un aplomb phénoménal il
maintient face à l'avocat général qui on
perd son calme que la rencontre avec
naomi est fortuite quand bien même
stationner thil depuis plusieurs heures
au pied de son bâtiment il maintient
également les relations sexuelles à
répétition
l'avocat général n'a pourtant que les
draps et serviettes ont fort commodément
disparu de la chambre rien de probant
pour la défense qui martèle nicolas
cepeda n'a jamais cherché à se
dissimuler ils réservent un véhicule une
chambre des billets d'avion à son nom il
paye avec sa carte bancaire si vous
aviez le projet de thuir une jeune fille
auriez vous laisser autant de traces
derrière vous demande son avocate
nicolas zepeda esquisse un demi sourire
charmeur bien loin du portrait qu'ont
dressé de lui les amies japonaises de la
victime en direct du japon ce matin
celle d'un homme qui faisait peur à
narui